the most astounding fact is the  knowledge that the atoms that comprise  life on Earth the atoms that make up the  human body are traceable to the  crucibles that cooked light elements  into heavy elements in their core under  extreme temperatures and pressures these  stars went unstable in their later years  they collapsed and then exploded  scattering their enriched guts across  the galaxy guts made of carbon nitrogen  oxygen and all the fundamental  ingredients of life itself these  ingredients become part of gas clouds  that condense collapse form the next  generation of solar systems stars with  orbiting planets and those planets now  have the ingredients for life so that  when I look up at the night sky and I  know that yes we are part of this  universe we are in this universe but  perhaps more important than both of  those facts is that the universe is in  us